[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight there is an awful lot
going on
just minutes ago the White House
released a letter saying the president
is inclined to declassify that
Democratic Committee memo and will work
with the House Intelligence Committee to
see if they can come up with a
releasable version of it much redacted
but that is not the only breaking news
tonight there's a lot more the Russia
story has suddenly become an FBI story
and it's moving faster than anyone
anticipated just a year ago all the
smart people were mocking Donald Trump
for being insane enough to suggest the
Obama administration had surveilled as
he put it wiretapped his campaign what a
paranoid lunatic they said get off
Twitter yeah now we know what actually
happened the question at this point is
how many people in Trump's orbit weren't
spied on by the FBI
Trump advisor Carter page was placed
under government surveillance in the
fall of 2016 after the feds used
uncorroborated claims from the Trump
dossier to justify a FISA warrant
we know from congressional testimony
that page spoke with Trump advisor from
campaign manager Steve Bannon while he
was being spied on
meaning that Bannon was likely spied on
to tonight based on our own reporting we
can tell you that Carter page also sent
email messages to members of the Trump
campaign during that same period
presumably the FBI intercepted those as
well so it looks like the Obama
administration may have spied on a
significant portion of the Trump
campaign team just how many people were
surveilled and to what extent how much
did President Obama know about it we
still don't have the answers to those
questions though we definitely have the
right to them oh no we don't say
Democrats asking questions is a sign of
disloyalty to this country the very
people who once told us that spying
absolutely never happened are now
telling us the spine was perfectly
justified and normal why because Russia
okay but the funny thing is almost all
of the Russian collegian evidence
unearthed recently implicates Democrats
not the Trump campaign yesterday we
learned that for example Senator Mark
Warner of Virginia was secretly sending
text messages to a lobbyist for Rush
oligarch in the hope of making contact
with the dossier author Christopher
Steele Werner tried to hide that
correspondence I'd quote rather not have
a paper trail he texted to the oligarchs
lobbyists now traditionally in
Washington anyway no paper trail is not
an indicator of transparency in fact
it's a sign of wrongdoing now we're not
saying that Senator Warner ought to
resign his seat and face treason charges
and we're not saying that because we're
not hysterical liberals willing to
poison our international relations and
misuse the justice system just for bleep
cheap political ends but we do think
that Warner's behavior is worth knowing
more about and so by the way is a
remarkable new New York Times story just
published about 40 minutes ago that
story alleges that within the last year
American intelligence agencies paid a
spy apparently a spy working for the
Russian government one hundred thousand
dollars in American tax dollars in
exchange for unverified and possibly
fabricated information about President
Trump now why would our intelligence
agencies use our money to do something
like that why would they do anything
like that under any circumstances and by
the way what was the information they
gathered used for none of that is clear
at this hour here's what is clear right
now the bottom line and what we've
learned this whole week the one thing
worth taking away from a dramatic week
in Washington is this the Obama
administration spied on a rival
political campaign there had better be a
legitimate reason for doing that but
increasingly it looks like there wasn't
Fox chief national correspondent and
Henry joins us with more on that
Russia Intel story yet well Tucker this
is just breaking this hour the New York
Times reporting that a shadowy Russian
tricked American spies actually out of a
hundred grand last year they promised
not just information on Donald Trump but
to deliver stolen national security
agency cyber weapons in a deal that this
shadowy Russian insisted would also
include yes compromising material on the
president sounds like a spy novel the
NSA has been devastated by losing these
secret hacking tools
so they delivered the cash in a suitcase
to a Berlin hotel room in September
supposed to be the first installment of
a million dollar payout here's the
kicker
the
rushon claimed the information would
link the president and his associates to
russia but instead of providing the
hacking tools Russian produced
unverified and possibly fabricated
information involving mr. Trump and
others bank records emails purported
Russian intelligence Etta sounds a
little bit like the steel dossier
several US and Telefilms tell us tonight
they made clear they did not want the
Trump material from the Russian they're
insisting they never wanted this he was
suspected of having murky ties to
Russian Intel into Eastern European
cyber criminals that's what they tell
the New York Times but it sounds like in
US Intel officials are kind of spinning
after the fact because they were in
negotiations the NSA even used its
official Twitter account nearly a dozen
times to send out coded messages to this
Russian the Russians eagerness to sell
the Trump direct raise suspicions among
American spies because it was part of an
operation to feed the information out
into the United States intelligence
community and pit US Intel officials
against mr. Trump it was confusing
because at one point this Russia dropped
his asking price from about ten million
dollars to just over a million dollars
that raised alarm bells then he showed a
15 second clip of a video showing a man
in a room talking to two women he
claimed it was mr. Trump but there was
really no way to confirm that it was mr.
Trump with two women it was a grainy
video it had no audio and we're told
that these officials were shown the
video in the Russian embassy in Berlin
so this does sound like a spy novel and
as you were just saying the president
some time ago was suggesting that the
some US Intel officials were out to get
him people said this is crazy that
wouldn't happen but now The Times is
reporting tonight a remarkable story
suggesting that they were willing to pay
a million dollars to potentially get
dirt on the president US intelligence
officials they gave $100,000 the first
installment and the shadowy Russian took
the money went away without any dirt on
the president Tucker
pretty unbelievable well actually
shocking very badly written story but
you summarized it very well
Philippe Raines was a longtime advisor
to Hillary Clinton was Deputy Assistant
Secretary of State under Obama and he
joins us tonight thanks coming up no
thank you
so I just got to ask you what what you
thought meeseeks sent you know about the
story that just broke but the bottom
line is
our intelligence community paid $100,000
to apparently a Russian agent for
salacious information of a sexual nature
unverified likely false about President
Trump
that doesn't seem standard well you know
what I think it's a couple of things and
why it does sound like a spy novel
unfortunately it's nonfiction it's what
we're living through I think the
intelligence agencies often have to pay
people who are not great to get
information we paid eight million
dollars to find out who the worst spy in
FBI history it was bar Bert Hanson I
think we paid 25 million dollars to
locate Khalid Sheikh Mohammed did you by
the nature sure and I'm glad that we did
that's why I'm glad too but that was an
extra I think this is an example of it
working because I don't know when this
from but you know what you haven't heard
about it and that's because it was
debunked exactly as ed was saying I
don't know I mean I guess just look
there's a lot that we don't know and so
I you know I don't want to presume
anything ever but the bottom line is our
government paid a hundred thousand
dollars of our money to buy fake
salacious material about the president
what would be the national security
reason for doing I think the bottom line
is that the president's campaign was
stocked with people starting with Carter
page who by the way was under FBI
surveillance going back to 2013 nothing
to do with the president's campaign he
his contacts warranted multiple
surveillance warrants starting in
October of 2016 for more times and mind
you do the math for more times takes you
into the Trump administration I'm aware
of that and you like a lot of people
who've abandoned concerns about civil
liberties are assuming that because
someone is under surveillance he's done
something wrong whereas I would argue
that the onus is on the government to
explain why you're spying on Americans I
think most people agree with you I
certainly agree with even the FISA Court
has a very high bar but no it actually
doesn't when we know that because almost
no applications for FISA warrants are
ever turned out if they were very few
ever made because everyone knows that's
the ratio okay this is chicken in the
egg but the truth is they're almost
never turned down and we know that in
this case the the dossier was the
backbone of the request it was the first
thing in the request we do know that and
we know that the dossier by the FBI's
own description was a flaky document
whose
they could not verify so look the bottom
line does it bother you if I said during
the Obama administration that the Bush
administration during the campaign had
spied on a bunch of members of Obama's
campaign team many were suspected
Russian agent but what if a year and a
half way there was no evidence that they
were Russian agents well and there's a
fine I mean would you say well geez you
know I better be a pretty you know
before you spy on a rival political
campaign using the FBI you know you
better be sure you've gotta grease an
interesting argument it's Carter Paige
part of the trunk campaign or not
because you'd make it sound like he was
the running mate except when it comes to
his contact he's thing to do with them
so it's not looking at the Trump
campaign oh no but here's the point what
they were using it look Carter Paige we
this show exclusively learned say
emailed a number of people mom the Trump
camp
it's called surveillance right and so if
you're surveilling Carter Paige she
never got paid he says he never met
Trump Trump says he never met him you
know whatever I wasn't there but that's
that's what we know about it I don't
think he was integral to the campaign
but he had contact with people on the
campaign and all of his conversations
both written and verbal were being
surveilled by the federal government is
to the Obama administration is spying on
the Trump campaign and mine are not
there well actually they literally were
bomb ministration thankfully took this
very seriously they went and got a
warrant on someone the warrant was based
on George papadopolis the dossier was
part of the warrant but the warrant was
primarily put that's not the point is
I'm just saying does it let's be totally
honest here the Obama administration's
spying on the Trump campaign maybe
there's an awesome reason for it no one
has explained that yet but you assume
that it's totally fine you would not
assume it was totally fine if it was
flipped around would you
I would assume I happen to trust their
government I know that these days that's
not a very savvy thing to say but I
trust their words President Bush or
President Obama Liza started in earnest
after 9/11 and I think we all learned
that it was important and if American
citizens are in some way acting as a
foreign agent then they're fair game
I'm sorry they're fair game but you have
to prove that they are and they didn't
and by the
there's no reason based on everything
we've learned in the past couple of
weeks to have childlike faith in our
intelligence agencies and I don't think
it's a good idea but bear in mind with
Carter page that it was renewed every 90
days three times but it was renewed
based on what happened in I didn't see
the applications and I think I think
well I'm happy that I would say
fortunately I don't control it I don't
know either fleep thank you no thank you
Doug